last thing I wanted to share was a lot
more work-related just from starting the
new job what I'm learning I'm definitely
making mistakes and one thing that I
genuinely absolutely love and I feel
like people should also love this even
though it's hard to take sometimes and
that is feedback so through that the
last sort of four weeks I've got
feedback and that's been good and bad
and I just think that for me personally
I love feedback because the way I view
it is it's an opportunity it's an
opportunity to basically do better next
time and it's just just it was just a
little insight and an experience I was
like I get why some people would find it
hard to be in the deep end or would find
it hard to to take constructive feedback
and you just can't take things like that
personally if you do you're gonna dwell
on it too much and the best way that I
think you should view it is take on the
chin view is an opportunity and
absolutely do your utmost to
over-deliver next time